[Music]
the loud house first aired in 2016 and
instantly became a Nickelodeon new
favorite with its quirky characters and
bold choices but sometimes the choices
may be so bold that they went a little
too far watch this video until the end
to see all the episodes and moments that
took the loud house out of everyone's
comfort zone you won't even believe this
show is for kids at times are you new to
the things
welcome give us a like and subscribe and
be the first one to be notified of all
of our new videos now on to ten times
the loud house went too far
nude pool swim the loud house has no
shortage of dirty jokes and moments that
probably took it too far for children
one of those moments was between the
loud children's parents in the episode
sweet and sour when the family goes on
vacation at the end of the episode Rita
and Lin senior go running by the pool
together giggling Rita is chasing Lin
senior and when they disappear off
screen we see their clothes thrown to
the side indicating they went
skinny-dipping those naughty parents
were having some alone time
aka doing the dirty well the kids
weren't around but their secret wasn't
kept for long in the next scene the two
parents sit together being punished for
their new dip in the pool they're
wrapped in robes and try to pay off the
pool manager with a button yes you heard
right a button so it is revealed that
the family was actually kicked out of
the hotel because Lin and Rita snuck in
after hours - well you get it sure some
parents might find this adult joke quite
funny but for kids we're not certain it
is entirely appropriate though the young
uns may have just thought they were
going for a little swim it's a tad odd
that they got completely naked in a
Nickelodeon show sneaky cam and the
episode cheater by the Dozen it is
hinted that Bobby might be cheating with
their neighbor the concept itself is
neither appropriate nor maybe even fully
understood by the kids Lincoln and his
best bud Clyde decided to see what's
going on in the neighbor's house by
touching a camera on top of the dog the
dog bolts into the house to reveal a
middle-aged woman saying to Bobby why
don't you slip off those clothes and
we'll get started
both Lincoln and Clyde gasp as he
removes his pants leaving him and only
his underwear the dog approached Bobby
with the camera and Bobby starts petting
him
giving the dog kisses Lincoln says it's
disgusting that he's now crossing
species there are one too many fetishes
referenced in this episode that are not
okay for children to see or even be
found funny by adults Lincoln and Clyde
then stalked Bobby to a secret Club and
watch him as he dances an Italian dance
with another man we're not exactly sure
where this one will be taken but it's
pretty certain that this joke was taken
too far also the two kids spying on
someone and then stalking them could be
seen as fun and innocent but following
someone into a downstairs Club
definitely crosses the line let's just
say we could have done without this one
grunt while you dance
remember that awesome game we all used
to love so much dance dance revelution
well this episode may have taken that
fun away from us in the episode dance
dance resolution the first problem is
that Lincoln avoids going to the dance
with Ronny so he can get the two-for-one
deal at the arcade obviously he's
confronted by his sisters who don't
agree with his decision and want him to
go Lincoln then lies and says she never
really asked him in the first place
this makes his sister's feel so bad that
they arranged some dates for him for
dates to be exact
finally Lincoln admits to Ronny an that
he should have let her take him to the
dance but she reveals to him that she
actually wanted to invite him to vrk to
talk about serendipity so off Ronny and
Lincoln go on their date to the arcade
they chose dance dance revelution but
instead of just stepping on the colors
they make weird grunting noises and
sounds that may be too suggestive for
young ears perhaps this was a mistake in
the voice recording room but we still
don't think it's appropriate for kids to
listen to that sibling stool samples
okay so where do we begin with this one
we mean it involves stool samples and we
aren't talking about kitchen stools but
like well you know number two in the
episode lock and loud the loud siblings
learn about security and begin taking it
way too seriously throughout the show
obviously this is a good topic to
promote to children to be safe but the
episode itself is filled with
inappropriate moments and as we
mentioned the stool sample bits the
siblings get geared up to protect anyone
from breaking in and stealing their
things they become so tight on security
that
home is almost as hard to approach as
getting into FBI headquarters when their
parents come home they refuse to let
them in before taking the needed
precautions they put in place Lisa gives
her mother a weird pat-down before
letting them into the house lisa says
she still needs that stool sample and
later continues to ask Lenny and Lloyd
for their samples as well when the girls
ask Lisa if it's okay for the same
security measures as before Lisa looks
awkward and says a yes that no one would
believe what is Lisa up to with taking
people's feces yeah
wieners and buns the tale of two tables
is a later episode in the first season
which means we already know the
characters and their personalities but
that still may not warrant what goes
down in this episode Lincoln doesn't
want to sit at the kids table and the
opening scene Lincoln is eating his
dinner and minding his own business when
someone starts poking him right in the
face with a wiener the Wiener continues
to poke him in the face until the poking
turns to multiple wieners slapping him
in the face
wait this is still a kid show right so
the Wiener poking continues and Lincoln
gets mad and goes to talk to his friend
Clyde about what he should do
Clyde never having to sit at the kids
table helps him Clyde sets up a table
simulation to teach Lincoln Clyde then
tells Lincoln who took Lori's bread but
that she shouldn't worry because he'll
share his buns with her uh what Lincoln
makes is suggestive movement with his
eyebrows to top that comment off so yes
we get some pretty suggestive stuff in
this episode especially if you're a
parent so let's be real no kid should
get their face hit with wieners in a
kid's show or you know ever girl crush
controversy there's likely a chance that
you've heard of this episode before in
the controversy that it brought to the
surface the majority of the episode is
solid but the ending is what made some
people angry in Ellis for love Luna has
a crush on the girl which is not what
the issue is however it was the reaction
from certain fans that made it an issue
we don't feel this episode took it too
far but the people who felt that Luna
shouldn't have a crush on a girl made
the episode quite popular and made fans
take sides seeing as the loud house was
the first mixture that had two gay
parents some fans felt that having
another gay character really pushed the
boundaries too far which really makes no
senses every other character is straight
so the LGBT community is rarely even
touched upon in a show that is open to
exploring that subject
it wasn't necessarily the episode that
pushed this one too far but the divide
and fans opinions over Luna having a
crush on a girl come on people it's the
21st century we think everyone can
handle that without causing drama what
do you think about this do you like
seeing a more diverse group of
characters Laurie tots so we all know
that Clyde has a little or shall we say
gigantic crush on Laurie his crush is so
massive he can't even speak around her
in the episode making the case Clyde has
trouble even thinking straight around
her which we have seen in previous
episodes before this one he loves
everything about her and one might even
say his obsession borders on creepy the
show started out with Lincoln mentioning
how he wants to win the trophy for the
fifth grade video contest
Lincoln decides that he's going to film
everything that his sister does all her
embarrassing moments to win the contest
so that's exactly what he does and then
he uploads them to the Internet first
off if anyone does that to anyone that
is a major invasion of privacy and also
illegal but the real moment we're here
to tell you about is when Laurie lets
one rip and passes gas Clyde's reaction
could be considered adorable or
downright too much he falls even deeper
in love with her saying it's music to
his ears now we can see why this would
be pretty funny but filming your
siblings and uploading embarrassing
videos without them knowing is
definitely taking it too far
however we'll let Clyde slide for liking
Laurie's farts momma's bum in the
episode the loudest yard there is a sort
of grotesque joke with Lincoln
apparently staring at his mother's butt
we later find out that he's taped a
comic book to her derriere and is
reading it but still insinuating a
character is attracted to his mother's
assets really is taking a kid show too
far mrs. loud attempts to make Lincoln
do aerobics with him which he obviously
isn't interested in finally he obliges
and they begin exercising together
Lincoln is behind his mother when she
moves in Chups following the video on
the TV it is then we see that Lincoln is
very interested in the site he is
positioned behind his mother with his
eye line looking at her tush
when mrs. loud says exercise can be fun
Lincoln responds that he reads her loud
and clear which leaves us thinking is
he's speaking about his mother's but not
at all the message that anyone should be
receiving then it is revealed that he's
reading a comic book but the sexual
innuendo and the joke towards his mother
just grosses us out look do you remember
this moment do you think that it pushed
the boundaries too far not the planet
there is a slew of dirty jokes in the
loud house and plenty that involved the
word Uranus sure we all know that it's a
planet but the implication behind many
of the times Lincoln says it is well not
speaking about the solar system that's
for sure Lincoln sits playing in the
dentist it mentions that he sees Uranus
from here and it's mighty gassy we're
pretty certain that writers didn't mean
the planet
sure this can be taken as an innocent
but joke but is it really needed among
all the other inappropriate jokes that
fill the loud house episodes and the
clip on YouTube many fans commented
below mentioning he's referring to the
planet and you need to get your heads
out of the gutter but we can't blame
them it's obvious that Lincoln is making
a joke and taking it one step too far
there are many other funny things that
can be said without - making references
to something so gross
how do you feel about all the Uranus
jokes that seem to pop up pretty
frequently in this next series do you
find them funny or just outright
disgusting let us know in the comments
section below
Lincoln's abuse the episode no such luck
takes a violent turn that borders on
representing child abuse or at least
that's how some fans feel this episode
became quite controversial due to its
treatment of our lead character Lincoln
loud Lincoln has some extra time on his
hands when his family sees him as bad
luck but that escalates quickly the
entire family starts to ignore shun and
punish Lincoln in different ways finally
even locking him out of the house and
putting a sign on the door Lincoln is
practically tortured almost every minute
of the episode he's forced to eat
outside and they even leave a note on
the door that reads sorry Lincoln but
you just can't sleep here tonight we
can't risk it even watching it in the
context of the episode is maltreatment
and definitely not right or justified at
one point the family goes to the beach
but they literally leave Lincoln behind
so he doesn't spread the bad luck why
treat anyone this way and if this wasn't
a cartoon the treatment of the person
would be overtly portraying child abuse
it's clear that the loud house took the
violence in this episode just too far
which moment do you think was the most
shocking and inappropriate are there any
moments that you noticed give us a like
and hit the subscribe button for more
great videos thanks for watching the
things and we'll see you next time
[Music]